vamos a practicar el simplificar
expresiones radicales que involucran
variables digamos que tenemos 2 x raíz
cuadrada de 7 x x 3 que multiplica a la
raíz cuadrada de 14 x x cuadrada causa
en el vídeo y vean si pueden simplificar
esto traten de encontrar los cuadrados
perfectos para sacarlos de aquí para
hacerlos a un lado y quitar esos
cuadrados perfectos del radical primero
simplemente vamos a multiplicar esto
podemos cambiar el orden de la
multiplicación por ejemplo esto puede
ser 2 x 3 x raíz cuadrada de 7 x x raíz
cuadrada de 14 x cuadrada esto va a ser
igual a 6 por el producto de 2 radicales
que podemos ver como la raíz cuadrada
del producto de estos tenemos 6 que
multiplica a la raíz cuadrada de 7 por
equis y permítanme factorizar el 14-14
es igual a 2 por 7 y ponemos aquí x
y la razón por la que no hicimos la
multiplicación directa de esto x por
equis cuadrada es igual a x al cubo y 7
por 14 es igual a 98 pudimos haberlo
hecho pero cuando tratamos de factorizar
cuadrados perfectos va a ser mucho más
sencillo si no tenemos de esta forma ya
factor izado especialmente porque desde
el punto de vista de la variable aquí ya
tenemos un cuadrado perfecto y 14 no es
un cuadrado perfecto y 7 tampoco pero 7
x 7 sí lo es 7 x 7 es un cuadrado
perfecto y es 49 podemos reescribir esto
como 6 por la raíz cuadrada de y primero
pongamos los cuadrados perfectos 49 que
viene de estos dos por equis cuadrada y
aquí nuevamente puedo separar esto en
dos radicales que es lo que nos queda ya
usamos el 7 el 7 y la equis cuadrada así
que nos queda el 2 y la equis solita
espero que puedan notar que estas dos
cosas son equivalentes en lugar de tener
un gran símbolo radical
tuviera 49 x cuadrada x 2 x x como aquí
arriba si tomamos el radical de el
producto de dos cosas será lo mismo que
el producto del radical de cada una de
estas cosas multiplicados en tres y esto
viene directamente de las propiedades de
los exponentes y ahora podemos
simplificar esto y nos queda 6 por la
raíz cuadrada de 49 el 7 y la raíz
cuadrada de x cuadrada es x así que nos
queda 7 x por la raíz cuadrada de 2x y
ya estamos en la recta final 6 x 7 es 42
42 x raíz cuadrada de 2x aquí lo
importante es apreciar que seguimos
usando esta propiedad de que la raíz
cuadrada de un producto va a ser igual
al producto de las raíces cuadradas de
hecho aquí pudimos tener un paso
intermedio pudimos decir que la raíz
cuadrada de 49 x cuadrada es igual a la
raíz cuadrada de 49 por la raíz cuadrada
de x cuadrada
y de ahí tenemos que la raíz cuadrada de
49 7 y la raíz cuadrada de x cuadrada es
x hagamos otro problema ahora digamos
que tenemos la raíz cuadrada de 2 a por
la raíz cuadrada de 14 al cubo por la
raíz cuadrada de 5 a nuevamente pausa en
el vídeo y traten de simplificar esto
multipliquen todo y traten de sacar del
radical los cuadrados perfectos que
encuentren esto va a ser igual a la raíz
cuadrada de 2 por 14 por 5 2 y 5 son
primos pero el 14 lo puedo factorizar
aquí adentro ponemos 2 por 2 por 7 por 5
y ahora tenemos a x al cubo por sumamos
los exponentes y nos queda a la quinta
que cuadrados perfectos tenemos aquí ya
vimos que hay uno con estos dos y a la
quinta no es un cuadrado perfecto si
pensamos en términos de la variable
pero esto es igual a la cuarta hora
vamos a acomodar esto y escribimos la
raíz cuadrada de al inicio ponemos
nuestros cuadrados perfectos dos por dos
es cuatro y aquí tenemos a la cuarta y
ahora ponemos todo lo que no es un
cuadrado perfecto 7 por 5 es 35 y
tenemos está a solita 35 a y como lo
vimos anteriormente
vamos a usar las propiedades de los
exponentes y decir que esto es igual a
la raíz cuadrada de 4 por la raíz
cuadrada de a la cuarta por la raíz
cuadrada de 35 a la raíz principal de 4
es 2 tomamos la raíz positiva y la
principal de la cuarta va a ser al
cuadrado y esto lo multiplicamos por la
raíz cuadrada de 35 a y con esto
terminamos este ejercicio vamos a hacer
otro más y en este caso vamos a
involucrar dos variables para que vean
que no es demasiado complicado vamos a
simplificar la raíz cuadrada de 72 x
cúbica z cúbica 72 no es un cuadrado
perfecto pero seguramente adentro tiene
un cuadrado perfecto si lo factor izamos
nos queda 36 por 2 y 36 es un cuadrado
perfecto de la misma manera x al cubo y
se da al cubo no son cuadrados perfectos
pero si los factor izamos encontraremos
una x cuadrada y una seta cuadrada en
ellos vamos a reescribir lo y poner
adelante nuestros cuadrados perfectos
así que esto es la raíz cuadrada de 36
por equis cuadrada z al cuadrado
y al final nos queda ya quitamos el 36
nos queda el 2 una x y una zeta
de esta x al cubo quitamos la equis
cuadrada por lo que nos queda una equis
y lo mismo con la seta de la zeta al
cubo quitamos seth al cuadrado y nos
queda una sola zeta y podemos verificar
esto multipliquen todo lo que tenemos
aquí adentro y verán que es igual a lo
que tenemos aquí arriba 36 x 272 x
cuadrada x x es x al cubo se está
cuadrada por zeta ceta al cubo y ahora
podemos factorizar esto directamente
vamos a hacer más pasos de lo que harían
ustedes si lo resolvieran por su cuenta
ya que el objetivo de este vídeo es
aprender aquí aplicamos las propiedades
de los exponentes todo lo que está aquí
adentro es un cuadrado perfecto la raíz
cuadrada de 36 por equis cuadrada x se
está cuadrada que a su vez es la raíz
cuadrada de 36 por la raíz cuadrada de x
cuadrada por la raíz cuadrada de zeta
cuadrada lo que nos da la raíz principal
de la
de 36 a 6 de la raíz cuadrada de x
cuadrada es x y la raíz cuadrada de zeta
al cuadrado la raíz principal es zeta y
esto lo multiplicamos por la raíz
cuadrada de 2 por x por 7 y con esto
terminamos